it was an intense two and a half hour
exchange of views in the hot seat
Commissioner Gunther Oettinger MEP
scrutinizes suitability to lead the
budget and human resources portfolios
which include among others managing to
2017 budget and Commission staff around
the world hunger was formerly in charge
of energy and more recently the digital
economy he was asked by Commission
President jean-claude Juncker to take
over new responsibilities after former
commissioner Kristalina Georgieva
resigned he faces political controversy
over comments he made about the Chinese
women and gay marriage that some deemed
offensive as well as meeting with way
more industry lobbyists than NGOs is LA
when east Nick minor op seat written da
Mountain MIT pinal cumin it's phillotson
when authorities to get freedom as I was
totally he having an affair aqui una
pinga kite Monica's own lobby poking
getting people he reiterated his
commitment to fighting for more
resources for Europe in a difficult
economic environment any peace have not
always agreed with the Commission's
choice and have in the past rejected a
candidate or ask portfolios to be
modified inert in jerz case there will
be no binding vote but the mepz
valuation can still put the Commission
under pressure
you